[Music]
you know if you listen to the show on
friday you would have heard a brief
segment about halfway in where we
discussed a recent census report which
shows that the white population in this
country has declined for the first time
in american history whites have dipped
below
60 of the overall population another
first and among young americans racial
minorities are now the majority
um now i say we discussed the report but
really we discussed more so the reaction
to the report which was positively
rapturous on the left the most blatant
example was jennifer rubin with
washington post who exclaimed that the
diminishing number of whites is
fabulous news
and elsewhere the celebration was
couched in more sanitized language but
was nonetheless apparent so take this
article
from a guy named peniel joseph with cnn
who scolded the white people who are
worried about the census data labeling
them all white supremacists to include
tucker carlson of course and joseph then
wrote and yet america's changing
demographics tell a different more
inspiring story rather than a narrative
of white decline what if we saw in this
data the increasing numbers of racially
blended families and mixed-race children
and understood and understood them as
signs of a more racially diverse
economically just and culturally rich
future
now it is he says inspiring for there to
be fewer white people around it is
more just and more culturally rich he
says
which is obviously to say that a whiter
country would be culturally impoverished
and less just
this is how the left has generally
framed it to be a less white country by
their telling
is to be a manifestly better country
that's why they celebrate the decline of
the white population it's why they
actively seek to
facilitate that decline
in terms of percentages by inviting
unchecked immigration across the
southern border
it's why they're very concerned about
making sure that white people have less
institutional power
and are really clear about that that's
that's what they want to do they put
policies like affirmative action into
place to achieve that end
now i said on friday that although this
is all obviously true
and they don't make any attempt to hide
it even so you're not allowed to point
out that any of this is happening
if you do you'll be accused of engaging
in the allegedly white supremacist
replacement theory
i also predicted during that segment
that media matters would post that same
segment and accuse me of advancing white
supremacist conspiracy theories well
like a prophet of old i had correctly
predicted the future once again so later
that day after that segment aired media
matters published this they say on
youtube daily wire host embraces white
nationalist conspiracy theory
now our friends of media matters are
nothing if not predictable but it wasn't
just them a woman named robin panacia
over at the wonkette blog posted an
article titled matt walsh scared we are
secretly trying to replace him and all
other white people
then she goes on
many years ago when we were all so much
more innocent the only people who
believed in the great replacement theory
were neo-nazis and when you tell normal
people about this even normal people who
were themselves kind of racist they
would be pretty surprised that it was
that it was a thing mostly because of
how it sounds ridiculous and also is in
fact ridiculous
but matt walsh doesn't think that only
rabid white supremacists should be able
to indulge themselves in absurd racist
fantasies in which they are the truest
victims he wants tactful suit-wearing
white supremacists to have that
opportunity as well why limit oneself
really now take a quick step to the side
here to say that
i'm not worried about this lady or media
matters calling me a white supremacist
that term has no meaning
i'm sure robin would call the barista at
starbucks a white supremacist if he
misspelled her name on her cup which by
the way they probably do all the time
incidentally because her parents
injected an unnecessary why into her
name a move that doomed her to a life of
writing whiny poorly constructed blog
posts like this one
the point is that these people find
white supremacy around every corner and
in every crack and crevice of the earth
to them i'm a white supremacist because
i exist
and i'm white and i lapse sometimes into
the nasty habit of expressing my own
opinions rather than their opinions
so the label could not be more
irrelevant to me with that said
i do take exception to the claim that i
am tactful and wear suits
those latter accusations are entirely
without basis i assure you in any case
reading a bit more here um after
extensively quoting me robin writes
quote
whenever anyone says you can't talk
about this they rarely mean that no one
can talk about it they just mean that if
they talk about it in the way they're
talking about it people will think
they're super racist which is a very
fair conclusion to reach almost any time
matt walsh's mouth is open and he's not
just saying things about women
we're letting people into america to
escape bad conditions in their home
countries
it's not for the purpose of replacing
white people no white people are being
murdered in the process of immigration
happening
well that's kind of news to me
as far as universities and positions of
power go no these can't all be for white
people that's not white genocide that's
just sharing white people are not
entitled to have all of the positions of
power it's not replacement it is making
things more fair
if one does think that white people do
have that intrinsic right then they are
in fact white supremacists oppressors
have always seen those they sought to
oppress as a threat this is nothing new
the best way to preserve an unjust
hierarchy is by convincing those at the
top in the middle that if those on the
bottom get any power they'll turn around
and do some oppressing themselves if
only as an act of revenge
now so it's a review
in case you're lost at this point
it is a racist conspiracy theory to say
that white people are being replaced
that's not happening at all
it's completely false how dare you
at the same time there is a racial
hierarchy in this country and white
people are at the top of it and are by
their nature oppressive and it's
therefore important to well replace them
with non-white people
indeed the people complaining about
being replaced are racist for not
wanting to be replaced and also for
claiming that they are being replaced
because they're totally aren't being
replaced even though they are and it's
good and they should like it but it's
not happening
make sense
no well of course not because the
incoherence is entirely by design
now back in realityville there is there
is no racial hierarchy that's not what
this is about
the hierarchy exists in the imagination
of women with unnecessary wise in their
names
the point the real point is simply that
at least partly as a as a result of
deliberate policy choices and the
actions of our most powerful cultural
institutions
the overall percentage of white people
in the country and of white people
admitted into universities and placed in
positions of power and so on
is being reduced
and non-white people are being placed
into those vacated areas
i think you could really call that
replacement but if you don't like
replacement that's fine let's put that
put that to the side how about a
different r word how about reduction
can i call it white reduction
nobody can deny that there's a
significant amount of white reduction
taking place both in the population and
especially institutionally
now
so we're talking about white reduction
um
the question
is it good
to celebrate this
and to answer that question all we need
to do is imagine how it would sound for
someone to celebrate the reduction of
any other race of people
what if i was to react to news about a
reduction in the black population by
describing it as
fabulous
now you'll argue that it's different
because black people are in the minority
but why should that make it different
the point is that minority or majority
we should not treat any race as a
pestilence that needs to be cured
you know to to treat any race as a
problem to be solved a plague to be
contained
is unimaginably unspeakably racist
and if you're really getting hung up on
the minority aspect of this then fine
imagine that i were to celebrate
the reduction of the majority race in
any non-white foreign country so let's
take any non-white foreign country
where non-white people hold all of the
systemic power
and then imagine that i were to tell you
that this majority race is being
supplanted by a minority race and that
this is great news
now you would surmise
that i'm obviously racist against the
majority race you would ask me questions
like well
why are you celebrating that exactly i
mean what's wrong with that race being
the majority why have you decided that
it shouldn't be why is it a problem what
what are you so excited about what don't
you like about these people
and if i responded that the majority
race is naturally oppressive and
inherently bigoted
and that's why there needs to be less of
them
you would only become firmer in your
conclusion that i am nothing but a
ranting raving drooling bigot
and you would be right in that case
and that's the point
okay
white people are not entitled to
positions of power that's that's true
and nobody is saying they are
that's not the point
here's what i'm saying about white
people here's my here is my radical
statement and media matters here's the
part that i want you to clip
because you're basically my pr team at
this point i tell you to clip something
and post it and you do which is great so
here clip this one
um here's what i'm saying about white
people this is this is my extreme
extreme claim
white people
have the same moral worth as anyone else
and are therefore entitled to the same
respect
so any language that would sound
horrifically racist when applied to
other races is just as horrifically
racist when applied to whites
that's what i'm saying
i am the one advocating for equality
here
treating treating all races the same
with moral worth
and we don't talk about them like
they're diseases to be reduced and
contained
robin and media matters they're the ones
who want to treat white people as a
special case
if only for negative reasons
and that is why they are today certainly
cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated